okay okay we're back [ __ ] just like
nine I don't know item size though avail
Stephan Googlers instruction okay holy
[ __ ] this is kind of hard to use this is
harder than I thought okay
it's a controls really weird like both
of them like left and right thumbstick
are like connected maybe I'll find our
[ __ ] ring down here oh [ __ ] right
without my channels on fire
okay here we go how's it worth up to
half huh but a great guy okay
[ __ ] man echo in there
I got to open up that okay
[ __ ] it I already figured that out
this guy should be like a writer or
something or like something okay I'm
really not kind of sure what why would I
listen to that complete cycle listen
this I'll just see if I can read this ah
they captured some ahead habla okay we
did it
okay here we go open that [ __ ] door
what's on here
they're almost annoying [ __ ] in this
whole [ __ ] game like it must be like
tricky because like
luck has gone on
ah
for the [ __ ] about there it is I feel
like my commentaries a lot more angrier
than him
he's like a nice common sense and I like
I [ __ ] [ __ ] alright stop out you know
out this book sucks
okay tip for anyone playing this game
it's a lot easier to just use one thumb
stick doll use both really
ah what is it
try of it in my attic attic downtown
is this that kind of some go again
the [ __ ] is all this [ __ ] what is this a
[ __ ] snake or some [ __ ] [ __ ] I got to
go take grant I'm stuck in a tunnel I
guess this is the end of this town
okay they're a lot or somewhere looking
for a ladder any ladder okay I guess
there's no ladder that's all right you
know like you can only expect so much
come on well faceted dig in I got it
here
can I access is there what is that
what's up [ __ ]
why are my supposed to be going anyone
else do anyone have any idea I came with
you there feel like I got to go over
there but there's not a lot letting me
do that
well I am so slow in swimming on top of
the water
are we clicking around quacks I'm just
looking around real quick and then high
up I catch it
oh noes on with the catch [ __ ]
pneumonia in here okay what is this go
ahead oh [ __ ] okay
am I missing something here
I guess I'm missing their way to crime
on top of this thing like a hell
there we go can I get on here now I
cannot what's up [ __ ] is going on here
maybe it was in the last area like maybe
I went too low too far ahead la tarea
did have some [ __ ]
let's say here
take this to the area to [ __ ] is that
how'd I just walk out of that okay ha ha
okay lawman hands let me stick it West
gander we go down that little tunnel
system again I'm not missing anything
and it holds on the ground quick you
guys there's no holes in the ground okay
now I can I can ascertain that I was not
so nice together
okay
go this way any ladders any ladders and
I like buckets stock and I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] or something this looks like
wires what they go okay look at the
ceiling
okay look I'm swimming all around
I don't really say [ __ ] in here get the
[ __ ] air okay
Wow
seriously like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
let's talk around myself I look at the
[ __ ] it's over here hmm
this is weird
oh wait what's up [ __ ] I guess I'm just
[ __ ] okay I'm tired yes interesting
not going to the water lips I got to go
over there
oh that's why I couldn't go there before
okay
holy [ __ ] let's get it [ __ ] on me no
matter
so [ __ ] down there like something
crawls inside
Hitler's ass and died in there and I'm
nervous but [ __ ] it let's go
come on
that's a blow one is to always [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
okay where am i God what the [ __ ] do
they explain eight-day distances this
guy's got some serious existential
crisis going on okay I guess I'm just
like here all right here we go
what the [ __ ]
train yourself for distribution things
first stick you the train okay
how'd I do that again
popular 1941 and our certain sort of
lazy
everyone different windows me of them
really getting really feeling pregnant
with the using okay so she hates an
others
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh yeah [ __ ] nice bucket rolling on a
lower place [ __ ] the [ __ ] dogs right
there up right there what's up [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Sharia now I know
I'm have to open that up okay okay
[ __ ]
right yeah
[Applause]
that dog [ __ ] knows at the 2nd mass
like is it oh [ __ ]
that we're to save now so this is
[ __ ] another guy here
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] okay time to go
the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we track is the wrong orientation
[ __ ]
now now
I'm trying to [ __ ] and get up here out
of town
okay so Toby's it's a [ __ ] to this
guy oh okay that's good that's good
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh I guess it's it not
okay had I shut
and
I am a little perplexed here it's just
like a lot of [ __ ] entrances now okay
so I think a little easier closing some
[ __ ] doors for me out what's over
here okay now they said this is a switch
nearby to [ __ ] change this [ __ ] right
[ __ ] a house I'll you there [ __ ] now
I can go this way so much for running in
this game there we go there we go
right
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that for sure buck
buck buck enter the door psych eval oh
okay we're an emissary I'm [ __ ] tired
I left out our guy
I'll clean anyone falling you know no
how come any new yes I definitely have a
stolen Hawk who needs to feel occasional
don't mess and you decide what makes Tim
yeah Anthony yeah obviously this is a
lower triangular you will hide into
torpedo force will slip it back into
main supply and she would wake up on the
you board for next time remember you
both we take it to set secret safe give
young things all about come on ma I'll
[ __ ] a fake you just hold the airs okay
Corral Johnny it in the torpedo once you
put the u-boat touch this thing into the
communication room and raise the antenna
boy we need radio contact
okay you're gonna write a fun action in
there this not dark dream seem to fade
too far out of reach now I just miss
your mind okay
we're gonna end this back thank y'all
thank y'all